This edition of the Scout National Podcast is brought to you by the folks at Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prizes for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom, at conohocreakcom.
And now to your scout master.
It's that time of year again. summer camp is right around the corner, and I have learned-
I have learned, folks- the secret of summer camp.
Summer camp is the art of learning how to be miserable and liking it.
We're all going to be uncomfortable at one point or another in our lives,
So we better be learned to be cheerful in miserable conditions at summer camp.
That's a great place to do it, isn't it?
Yes, sir, This is podcast number 175..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mail bag Got a couple of people wrote in this week.
Hey, we heard from Michael Harrington and he had this to say about our last podcast
where we talked with our friend Arlam Ward and we got an update on his new troop out there in Colorado.
Michael said this podcast just addressed in a nutshell all of our troop experiences
and all of our challenges during patrol leaders council meetings
and troop meetings and camp outs and all of the adult involvement.
We're in Massachusetts, yet if you remove the names and places, I would have bet my bottom dollar
you were talking about our troop. It's amazing, isn't it?
We all go through the same stuff. That's why it's so much fun, right?
That's why sometimes this whole conversation and the podcast and the blog and things like that is useful,
because we're all doing the same thing, We all run into the same difficulties,
We all celebrate the same achievements, and it's just what makes the world go round, isn't it?
Daniel Desjardins wrote in to say:
my two sons are in a new troop because we moved
At this time. most of the troop is run by adults. The scout master, although, is retiring in October
and I will have the pleasure to take over the position.
Congratulations, Daniel. Jump into the volcano. It's fine.
I've been scouting for a long time, but this will be the first time I attempt being a scout master.
I have been listening and reading everything you've done
and one thing that I will put in place will be a patrol leader's council,
and we're going to have the scouts be in charge just like they ought to do.
Keep on scouting. People like you make a difference.
Well, thank you, Daniel. Thank you for your kind words of encouragement. there
You're going to have the opportunity to go ahead and give this stuff a go
and see how it works- and it works. It works, Trust me.
It won't look like it's working at first, but it will work for you.
It's summertime. We're still keeping busy at ScoutMasterCGcom.
I posted a video this past week about an axe and a knife and a sharpening stone
that you would want to take a look at.
So go to our YouTube channel, ScoutMasterCG. on YouTube
and, you know, check out the review of those items on the blog.
They came from our friends at ConahoeCreekcom,
So you want to make sure to check those out.
I think they're well worth your attention.
Well, on this Scout Master podcast and Scout Master ship, in seven minutes or less.
it's never, ever seven minutes
And it's certainly not less than that.
But you know, oh well, we're going to talk about summer camp,
because that's where we're all headed.
I have some advice for you about that and we've got an email question to answer,
and that's going to do it for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Master ship in seven minutes or less.
It won't be too long before we're all packed up
and ready to take our big crowd of Scouts to summer camp.
I am looking forward to it, as I do every summer.
This will be summer number 29, or maybe 29..
Yeah, I think summer number 29..
A lot of those summers my role at summer camp was being on staff
instead of being the Scout Master for our troop.
I did that for about a dozen years in different senior positions
and a couple of those were as the camp director.
That many years of working at camp and the couple of years being a camp director
and keeping up with our current staff-
And I can tell you something: things haven't changed a great deal.
The program, oh, that changes a little bit and you know different people come,
but the same issues are the perennial issues,
that kind of make or break your week at summer camp.
We've attended the same summer camp since the troop was first chartered in the 1940s.
Some of you like to go to different camps every year, try out different things, you know,
and that's all good.
I don't think there's a right or a wrong way to do it.
The right thing is getting out for a week at summer camp
After all those years on staff and having spent a long time as a Scout Master at camp
and watching you know literally thousands of Scout leaders
and tens of thousands of Scouts go through a summer camp week.
I can tell you- I believe authoritatively- that these are the most important things
for you to be thinking about as an adult who's going to spend a week at camp.
The number one thing is: don't overdo it and kind of make yourself into a time bomb. okay,
If you get hungry or hot and tired and thirsty, you need to pay attention to that
and you need to get cool and rested and fed and hydrated.
I know I get pretty cranky if I don't look after myself,
and years of observation prove that many of my fellow Scouts share the same problem.
When you're going to spend a week at camp with a group of Scouts,
the temptation is going to be to try to keep up with them.
Now, more power to you if you can do that and not feel any effects.
but most of us aren't 16 anymore, right?
So we have to look after ourselves and looking after yourself.
most importantly, that you get hydrated and rested is really, really important,
because if you turn yourself into this kind of ticking time bomb
so that by the end of the week you have no patience left
and you're getting a little touchy and you're getting kind of cranky.
it's going to make everybody's life miserable.
So that's probably that's the number one thing
and that's why it's at the top of the list.
Number two: I can tell you that the camp staff is totally dedicated
to making your stay at camp worthwhile.
I can tell you that
I know that I've been to National Camp School-
I think I went to five different years of that-
and I know people from camps all over the country
and I know that they put their heart into it.
None of them are in it for the money-
The money is not good-
but they're there because they want to make this a great experience
for the scouts and, in turn, for the adults
that are accompanying the scouts there.
One of the great experiences at a summer camp
are the younger people who are on the staff of the camp.
They're learning and growing, just like your scouts are,
and you need to be considerate and supportive of them.
That is a really important way to make life better while you're at camp:
to be considerate and supportive of the staff,
because that's what they're trying to do for you.
Number three: no matter how much you think they deserve it,
never berate or criticize or argue with or yell at
a staff member, a youth leader or a fellow adult leader
in the presence of your scouts.
If it really needs to happen,
a quiet talk at an appropriate distance, out of earshot from scouts,
will usually solve the problem
and a lot of times- if you're like me,
you're going to find out- the problem might be yours.
Number four is not to pull rank.
You should understand what that means.
Let's say you're a scout master
and you go down to camp with your troop.
Well, you're a scout master,
You're not a general or an admiral or the president.
so there really isn't any rank for you to pull, is there?
Most people instantly respect the position that adults occupy
at camp.
The staff respects it and the scouts respect it.
So don't make a big giant deal out of it.
Don't ask for special privileges
or try to impress staff members with yourself importance
or your encyclopedic knowledge of the things that they are doing.
They're very proud of what they are doing.
They're working hard to do it
and you going in there
and telling them everything you know about it
is not necessarily going to be very welcome.
I'm in a situation where I used to be the camp director at the camp
and I used to be on staff.
I've been going there longer than any staff member has
right at this point,
but I don't expect to be treated much differently
than any other scout leader.
It's important that I keep that attitude
and that I play the game
and I go by the rules
and I don't expect any special favors.
Number five is: join in the program
and encourage your scouts to join in too.
If you travel around,
if you go to a different camp every year,
you're going to hit a program that you don't like-
It's almost inevitable-
and you're going to hit a program
that maybe, in your humble opinion, isn't all that great
and a staff that's not all that great.
Well, I got to tell you from the staff side of things:
a lively, appreciative, supportive audience
does more than anything
to enliven and energize a camp staff.
Just being nice,
You know,
Even when things are going wrong,
even when you think things are not great
and maybe even that you're being mistreated,
it doesn't cost much to be nice.
There is a nominal kind of customer relationship, right,
You plunk down money
and your scouts plunk down money to go to camp
and you expect a certain level of service
and accommodation and things like that.
Well, you know, let's remember,
a scout camp is not club med
and a scout camp is not necessarily going to be
a highly polished professional atmosphere
of, you know, absolute excellence.
Camp staffs go through cycles.
They have down years and they have up years
and camps go through cycles like that.
You know, the whole idea in all of this
that I am saying is being a little humble
and being cooperative
and not complaining and grousing
and being kind of that disgruntled customer.
If you have a very bad experience,
you'll want to talk to somebody.
but I got to tell you
the 15-year-old staff member,
the guys that are working at camp,
they're not the ones that are going to be able to change things.
You want to get in touch with somebody
at the council office.
You want to talk to the camp director. maybe,
like I said, your attitude
is going to have a great deal to do
with the quality of your experience.
Number six is to participate
in ceremonies and traditions
and practices of the camp,
even if they're not very familiar to you.
and you know, I'll say again,
even if you really don't care for them all that much.
A camp staff is very proud of its traditions.
Imposing your way of doing things
on a camp staff,
imposing your traditions on them,
is really kind of rude.
It's like going into somebody else's house
rearranging the furniture.
Play along.
There's going to be a specific way
that a camp- take you know,
has a retreat ceremony
and that's going to be a tradition that they've had
and developed over a number of years
and it's what people are used to
and you know it. may
there may be little details
of it that rub you the wrong way,
but listen, play along,
Have a good time.
You know the way that they do a campfire
and the way things are done in the dining hall,
the way that merit badge sessions are set up.
go along with it and do your best
to encourage your scouts to do the same.
Number seven: you want to keep an eye
on any kind of inner troop rivalries
that may develop.
You know, for the most part,
your scouts are going to be out and about
pretty much independently during the day
and they're going to be running into other scouts
and you have absolutely no control
over what other scouts are going to do
and you have, you know, only a little bit of control
over what your scouts are going to do
or say. and boys are boys
and they get real competitive
and sometimes that can lead to things
that aren't very productive.
So you want to watch out.
I'm not saying that any of this is necessarily negative,
but often with scout age boys,
the idea of sportsmanship
is not necessarily always foremost in their mind.
So you want to talk about that
and you want to check in on that
and make sure that your scouts,
at least that, are very sportsman-like
and fair-minded and courteous.
Number eight is something that we say all the time:
give your youth leaders all the responsibility for success.
see that they understand what needs to be done at camp,
how and why it needs to be done,
and then let them at it
and observe from a distance.
check in with them every evening,
check in with them every afternoon,
ask lots of questions,
make sure that they are familiar with the program.
if somebody comes down to our campsite
and they're looking for somebody in charge,
I send them to the senior patrol leader
and the senior patrol leader works with the patrol leaders
and they have a great time at it,
because summer camp is a great patrol building time.
you can really make something out of that opportunity
if you give the youth leaders the full responsibility
for making their week a success.
Number nine is: be proud of your scouts.
encourage them and congratulate them and admire them,
but don't try to be one of them.
remember you're the coach, you're not a player.
don't get on the field, don't try and join in the youth activities.
let the scouts enjoy them.
every once in a while
the opportunity to jump in at the scout level
may present itself,
but don't interfere.
and I have seen that type of thing happen
a great deal at camp.
you know it's exciting and it's fun
and the scouts are having a great time,
that they want to do the same type of thing
and it doesn't work really well.
so keep an eye on that.
Number ten is be patient with yourself.
be patient with your scouts,
be patient with the camp staff.
don't sacrifice the perfectly good for the perfect.
there's this kind of thing that happens
when a scouter goes to camp and he's very closely identified
with his scouts and the troop and everything like that
and every little thing seems to matter.
they always walk around camp.
what they do at a retreat ceremony,
the way that they act in the dining hall
and things like that
is some kind of personal reflection
back on the scouter
and scouts can get a little testy about that
and they get defensive about it.
it really tends to color the whole way
that they're approaching the camp experience.
the camp is there for the scouts.
they'll take care of you,
they'll help you.
they'll probably even have some activities
scouters to do.
in the end you've got to be patient,
you've got to roll with the punches
and don't take yourself all
that seriously.
so those are ten things that,
from my experience as a scout master
and as a camp director,
I hope will help you have a great week at summer camp.
you're my favorite all time boy scout.
he's my favorite all time boy scout.
oh yes,
we had it tough,
but that's the way it was
and by golly we
like to taste.
our hiking and camping
was accomplished in the face of
deprivations.
you can only imagine,
wow, that would be hard.
for example,
is that when we wanted pudding,
we had to assemble it
from its constituent
ingredients
and labored long and hard
to enjoy the result.
wow,
we could only dream of
popping the top off a can
and enjoying prepared pudding.
jeez,
was an impossible,
crazy dream
in the hazy, distant future.
I'm glad I don't have to do that.
you can cut your finger on those lips.
we had to work hard for what we wanted.
nothing was handed to
us on a silver platter,
I can tell you.
we knew how to delay gratification
in my day.
can you imagine
that when we wanted to communicate
with one another, we used the agency
of something called the telephone?
it was an instrument attached
to a wire and it had
to be laboriously dialed
to initiate a connection?
jeez,
not only that,
we had to share this device
with our entire family,
as individual connections
for each of us would have constituted
a prohibitive expense.
wow, your whole family, really.
wow, that would be horrible,
yes, but we knew no different
and so lived in a state of relative happiness.
unlike you lads today
who demand so much
and are willing to suffer little,
my generation
was able to apply themselves
more stringently to the everyday
challenges life
required of us.
hey, Mr M, I think that's your cell phone.
um, yes,
pardon me.
yes,
yes, that's right.
yes, we're in campsite
number 24.
rest assured, I will be prepared
for your arrival.
jeez, Mr M, who was that?
um, nothing, really.
no one of any consequence.
perhaps it's time you, lads
initiated preparations
for your dinner.
yeah, yeah, you're right. see you later.
come on, guys.
hi, is this
campsite number 24?
yes, indeed,
please moderate your voice
not to disturb the rare day sleeping
nut hatch that nests nearby.
all right, uh, yeah,
whatever. well, here you are, my fine
fellow 2495.
the difference
between the stated price and these
bills is yours to keep.
well, thanks, buddy,
enjoy your pe-. please.
I'm sorry, the nut hatch,
enjoy your pizza.
time is again for another
exciting episode in the career
of
mason
scout master.
write me a letter,
send it by name
email. that is folks.
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
gary courier is with troop 15
in charlotte, north carolina,
and he wrote in to say:
I love your website. it's very informative,
like your feedback on the patrol
leaders council with regards to
who books the reservations
for camping trips and events and
things. we do an annual planning
meeting where the scouts select
the activities for the next year,
and then we have
uh,
and then we have an adult
volunteer make the reservations for
the activities. should the scouts be
doing that, or is that too much to
ask? i think an adult needs to do this.
it may involve things that a scout
can't handle, like signing contracts
or making payments. what are your thoughts
on this? well, jerry, thanks for getting in touch.
I'm glad you're finding the information
at scoutmastercgcom useful.
my rule of thumb
is this: don't do anything
a scout can do.
that's not an original thought
by any means. that's been around scouting
for a long time and you've really got to
kind of apply this on a case by case basis.
some senior patrol leaders, some
patrol leaders, councils, may have the capacity
to call and make reservations
and some won't.
okay, it really depends on their
ability and their familiarity with doing it.
it may be a good opportunity to teach
them how to do stuff like that
and communicate with other adults and things.
I would never make it a hard and fast rule.
I like the rule of thumb: don't do something
a scout can do. I've had senior
patrol leaders who are way,
way far ahead of me. they've made
reservations and they've
found out about places to go and they
get the driving instructions
and things like that, and that's great.
and I've had ones that are a little less
experienced and need a lot of help
making those things happen. and, as
you said, there are some things that
adults have to do. it's
going to be down to somebody from the committee
or something like that doing they're going to have to
file tour plans,
they're going to have to write checks and sign contracts.
so I think it's very right
in principle that there are situations
where scouts can do this
and others where it really needs an adult.
in my experience, it depends on the capability
of the scout, the type of
arrangements being made and the complexity
of the situation that you're in.
I think it's a great idea if it's
possible for scouts to go ahead
and do this and have the guidance to do it,
because they're learning yet another skill.
thanks, Jerry, for sending that question
in. if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch and I'll tell you
how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at
scoutmastercgcom
while you're there. you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to this podcast,
the scoutmaster podcast, on iTunes
and on Stitcher smart radio.
you can get details about
how to subscribe at stitchercom.
you can experience all the wonders
of the vast
offerings of scoutmastercgcom
through the panorama of
social media.
how about that?
you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook, tweet
scoutmastercg on twitter
and for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle. search for
scoutmastercg on google plus
plus
and
and make sure you check out our youtube channel:
scoutmastercg at youtube.
now, if none of that appeals to you, well,
you can zoom into the 90s
and send me a good old fashioned
email.
you can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at Clark CLA
RKE
at scoutmastercgcom.
it only remains
for me to tell you
that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
nope, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and group camping
why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.